Kennedy gave a speech on the Senate
floor today expressing as much you know
what the American people are thinking
right now mr. president they're thinking
that this country was founded by
geniuses but it's being run by a bunch
of idiots what are we going to leave to
our children if we allow this economy to
crash
senator Kennedy joins us tonight senator
thanks so much for coming on you've been
in Washington a while I certainly have
I've never seen anything really like the
Democratic version of this bill it
almost read like a parity and again I'm
not being partisan here I'm being
sincere did they think that this was
going to be enacted into law do they
believe that mandating diversity
officers in corporate America is an
appropriate response to coronavirus was
this I think that they think that they
have the Republicans over a barrel and
the president you know reality calls and
Congress is hanging up I meant what I
said on the floor talk more charitable
Americans are thinking to themselves
well there's some good members of
Congress but we can't figure out what
they're good for less charitable
Americans are saying you know how did
these morons make it through the birth
canal I mean people are losing their
jobs they're losing their savings
they're losing the 401 K we think we
know how to get the economy back on its
feet over the next 60 to 90 days until
we can get control of the virus and some
of my colleagues they're acting like us
I'm sorry I'm not saying they mean to
but nonetheless they're killing it
there's they're just throwing in every
every special interest political war
not need thinking that they can Ram it
through but because we're too scared to
vote against it and it's just wrong man
it's just wrong but it's also
counterproductive I mean this isn't
renaming a post office this is something
of real interest to the whole country
and people are paying attention did they
think that no one was gonna notice what
was in the bill
III don't know I'm not sure they're
thinking at all I mean I saw a press
conference by the speaker and I mean no
disrespect to her but basically she was
saying she wants President Trump to come
out and endorsed Obamacare now that's
not gonna happen you know that and I
know that they they have the provisions
you well you did a good job in your
commentary corporate board versus
diversity same day of Mexican
registration when correct tax credits
solar tax credits I mean this stuff it's
basically they want the green new deal
and they're saying if you Republicans
don't endorse it we're going to strangle
the American people economically now
look for a small segment of our
population it's true
the corona virus can kill you for a
small segment but you know what else can
kill you
poverty hunger losing the entire economy
and and we need to stop thinking about
the next election and try to think a
little more about the next generation
and what we're going to leave to them
which is gonna be the little end of
nothing if we let this economy collapse
and it's avoidable we can stand it back
up but we don't have we don't have the
months to do it we've got days it does
seem that way it does feel like we've
got days I I agree with that senator
thanks so much for coming on tonight and
assessing this abomination and it really
is an abomination for the letting off
too
it beats anything obviously saying
thanks [ __ ] it's unbelievable thank
you